SEE YOU TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
NEW YORK, CALIFORNIA, AND
WASHINGTON HAVE SOME OF
AMERICA’S LARGEST HOMELESS
POPULATIONS, THEY ALSO HAVE THE
THREE WORST CORONAVIRUS
OUTBREAKS.
SUDDENLY HAVING A POPULATION
THAT LEAVES NEEDLES AND GARBAGE
EVERYWHERE AND DEFECATES ON THE
SIDEWALK DOESN’T SEEM SIMPLY
DISGUSTING THOUGH IT IS IT SEEMS
DANGEROUS AND INSANE.
JASON RANCE SON SEATTLE AREA
RADIO HOST JOINS US TONIGHT.
JASON, THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
LOOK, WE CAN’T -- WE ARE NOT
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS WE DON’T KNOW IF
THERE IS A DIRECT CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE FILTH WE MENTIONED
AND OUTBREAKS THEY ARE SEEING
NOW.
THERE IS NO PROOF OF THAT BUT,
CLEARLY, THIS IS A WAKE-UP CALL
FOR CITIES THAT YOU CAN’T HAVE
CALCUTTA LIKE CONDITIONS
DOWNTOWN, NO?
>> IT SHOULD BE, I AM GROWING
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED THE MORE
WE HEAR ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS DOESN’T SPREAD SEEMS
TO MAKE SENSE TO ME BECAUSE I
LIVE IN A HOME AND I HAVE ACCESS
TO HAND SANITIZER, SOAP AND
WATER.
HOMELESS PEOPLE DO NOT.
WE HAD A CASE TODAY -- YOU AND I
LAST WEEKEND TALKED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
AND WHERE IT INTERSECTS WITH
CORONAVIRUS.
SOMEONE LAST NIGHT WAS PUT INTO
A MOTEL IN A CITY NEARBY SEATTLE
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE AN
ISOLATION SITE.
THEY SUSPECT THIS INDIVIDUAL WHO
WAS HOMELESS HAS CORONAVIRUS.
THEY ARE WAITING FOR THE TEST.
WELL, THIS MORNING HE LEFT THE
SELF-QUARANTINE SITE, WENT
ACROSS THE STREET TO A 7-ELEVEN
WHICH HE ALLEGEDLY ROBBED AND
THEN HE JUMPED ON TO A BUS AND
HE LEFT.
THAT IS A PROBLEM.
WHEN WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF SUPPORT
SERVICES, BECAUSE THEY ARE
LIVING WITH POTENTIALLY A MENTAL
ILLNESS, AN ADDICTION, THEY ARE
NOT NECESSARILY GOING TO BE PUT
IN A POSITION WHERE THEY CAN
JUST SELF-QUARANTINE.
THEY NEED THE HELP.
AND WE HAVE YET TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH PLAN
PRESENTED TO THE PUBLIC THAT IS
ADDRESSING THIS PARTICULAR
CONCERN.
>> Tucker: SO IN OTHER WORDS IF
YOU ALLOW YOUR CITY TO FALL
APART WHEN A CRISIS COMES IT
MIGHT CLASP COLLAPSE COMPLETELY.
>> THIS IS A LONG TIME CONCERN.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN CALLING THIS
OUT AND SAYING YOU CANNOT ALLOW
THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS TO GET
THIS OUT OF CONTROL.
YOU HAVE TO ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
SEMBLANCE OF A PLAN.
AND SIMPLY SAYING WELL, WE ARE
NOT GOING TO SWEEP PEOPLE FROM
THESE ENCAMPMENTS AND PUT THEM
IN THE SYSTEM BECAUSE WE WANT TO
PURSUE POLITICALLY IDEOLOGICALLY
DRIVEN POLICY PRESCRIPTIONS,
REMEMBER, WE HAVE A HOMELESSNESS
SITUATION THAT THE CITY COUNCIL
AND THIS MAYOR PRETENDS IS A
DIRECT RESULT SOLELY ALMOST
SOLELY ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THEY BLAME AMAZON.
AMAZON IS DRIVING UP THE RENT.
>> Tucker: THAT’S A LIE.
>> I’M SORRY, THAT’S NOT THE
REASON.
AND WAITING TO ADDRESS THE
ACTUAL UNDERLYING CAUSES SO YOU
CAN PASS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
POLICIES, THAT’S A PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: TOTALLY.
SAY THIS AS SOMEONE WHO DESPISES
AMAZON AND I MEAN THAT I TRY NOT
TO USE AMAZON AS MUCH.
I DISLIKE THEM.
THEY ARE NOT THE CAUSE OF THIS,
YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.